I know I can't believe it that the new
iPhone is about to be released and I'm
not sure if I'm ready like where did
this year go is it just me or did this
year go so exceptionally fast I don't
know anyway before the big event happens
at Cupertino I thought I would go
through and see some last minute rumors
what are we expecting in the iPhone 15.
I've done several of these videos not a
lot has changed I feel like a lot of
stuff got leaked super early but let's
see if there's anything new this first
article that I've seen is the iPhone 15
it's four things that make this a fun
upgrade this year I wonder what those
could be
USBC surprise this has been something
that has been rumored for a very long
time I would say the last three iPhones
maybe which this is actually really
great because this is a perfect time for
you guys to stock up on
the iJustine pink USBC cables there's
various lengths and of course they are
pink and there is a lifetime warranty
I've got a link in the description if
you want to check these out I hope that
you enjoy them and of course if you
aren't planning to upgrade this year and
you do have an iPhone that has a
lightning cable don't worry we've also
got the lightning cables and we even
have a thunderbolt cable which is not
gonna lie my personal favorite I mean
have you ever seen a thunderbol for pink
cable before no yeah well yes you have
because you're seeing it right here
anyway continuing on to number two the
Periscope camera catches up to Samsung a
periscope a telephoto camera lens has
been one of the most anticipated and
perhaps even one of the most customer
requested I don't know if that's
something that a normal customer is
requesting that no this is
most normal consumers are not going to
be like oh hold on I would like a
periscope no absolutely I don't even if
you went out on the street right now and
you asked a hundred people what a
periscope camera is I am almost
guarantee seeing that they would be like
I don't know what you're talking about
so a periscope camera I don't think is
one of the most customer requested items
I would say maybe USBC maybe that's even
pushing it because I feel like most
customers don't actually care they want
their phone to charge they want to be
fast they just want it to work so I
think that I don't
I know now that's not to say that once
we get the Periscope camera everyone
will know what it is and they're going
to be like well we can't live without a
periscope camera now right I
optimization this is actually pretty
cool because this action button much
like the well I'm not wearing it right
now on the Apple watch Ultra has a new
action button that you can assign to do
specific tasks this is going to be
pretty cool because you'll not be able
to uh assign the action button to do
something so cool what are you gonna
have your action button do
yeah number four titanium it's gonna
make it tougher and lighter I was always
a big fan of the titanium Apple watches
so this is pretty exciting that they're
now going to be bringing titanium to the
iPhone 15. super hyped about that I'm
also curious because I've seen some
rumors about the new Apple watch Ultra 2
coming in a matte black titanium which I
think is going to be super sick so I'm
hoping that that actually happens oh my
God it's beautiful it's so freaking sick
there's also a little rumor here that is
saying that the new Apple watch series 9
is going to be available in pink this is
where I'm getting a little upset you
guys
that is okay that's barely pink that's
like a not I like it I love it I need
some more of it is the problem I won't
like I want hot pink like let's just go
all in apple if you were gonna do it
this year if you were gonna make a hot
pink phone or a hot pink item like this
is the Year this is the year of Barbie
okay
let us have pink I hurt my hand
in this macramers article it's saying
the iPhone 15 camera upgrades will be
the star of the show at the Apple event
which great I mean I feel like I don't I
mean the iPhone is usually the star of
the show the iPhone 15 plus and 15 will
be equipped with a stacked camera sensor
that'll be supplied by Sony so thank you
to my friends and Sony they're saying
the previous reports the sensor will be
able to capture more light and the
research firm said this will allow for
proof dynamic range in photos grade I
want I want better photos I want better
video the one thing that I'm hoping the
thing that has driven me absolutely wild
this year in the iPhone 14 is the
minimum Focus distance and switching to
macro now I know we can turn that off
but I do feel like I want the minimum
Focus distance on the main camera to be
a little bit closer I do love macro but
there are times where it switches a
macro and it just kind of degrades the
quality of the photo that I'm trying to
take so fingers crossed that minimum
Focus distance in the main lens is
a little bit a little bit better this
year additional features lighter weight
titanium frame yup customizable action
button yup a17 bionic yep Wi-Fi 6E
support great cool so here's a couple
renders of some photos of iPhone 15 this
isn't the pro which I wish it was
because that is the pink that I want
that is the pink that I love and it is
so beautiful that pink could quite
possibly be the color that makes me want
to have that phone be my daily driver
but I'm gonna want the mate I want the
pro Max though so badly I just this is
this is a conflict just think that
pink should be for everybody it should
be a pro color it has the potential now
obviously those super bold colors are
incredible but unfortunately 95 Mac here
has some bad news for us and they're
labeling these colors boring these are
some late colors that are supposedly the
iPhone 15 like this entire year ever
since the first leaks like we have seen
those beautiful bold colors and then
like here this kind of gets pushed out
there so maybe this is Apple's way of
deterring us from thinking that the bold
colors are going to be there I don't
know judging by the color of that pink
Apple watch which was a more blush color
it would make sense because it would
kind of match these muted tones but
these are so muted they they are a
little boring I mean like give us the
pink that's all I want this is showing
us the iPhone 15 Pro dummy udence and
interesting these are the most boring
color options they are definitely
something these all kind of look the
same I mean normally these leaks never
actually get the colors 100 so I still
feel like there's going to be a red
phone remember like that was the thing I
don't know but in this math rumors
article they're showing this blue color
which is actually very pretty so like
I'm not super opposed to that and also
this looks like a darker kind of
graphite in between like the silver and
the black so like I'm kind of into that
not gonna lie so here's a recap of all
of the things the iPhone 15 Pro would
have of course the titanium frame the
I-17 bionic chip the action button USBC
new color options Titan gray I'm
obsessed with that blue silver and space
black ultra thin curved bezels Wi-Fi 68
gigs of RAM a periscope telephoto lens
this will give you up to five or six x
optical zoom and this is exclusive to
the a15 pro Max more repairable design
Ultra wideband improvements SIM card
slot removed in most countries yeah yes
yes yes I love this article from
macaroom resistance what not to expect
at the event on September 12th M3
powered Max nope an M3 chip nope new
iPads no iPhone se4 no Vision Pro
headset nope that's definitely going to
be a next year thing I for sure feel
like that's going to be its own special
event can't wait for that well guys
that's it I mean as you know the iPhone
season is my time to shine it is my
favorite time of year so I look forward
to getting some more coverage from you
guys here if you want to check out any
more of my videos they will be at here
on the end screen and of course you can
check out more info on my main YouTube
channel youtube.com iJustine tons of
content for you guys to check out there
see you guys soon bye